hi I'm Michelle Klein member of the GSB
Alumni Association board and I'm pleased
to welcome you to this production
[Music]
regret for what you have done can be
tempered by time
regret for what you have not done
is inconsolable
I want to tell you a story
a few weeks ago a former student from a
number of years ago made a zoom
appointment
I was pleased and a bit surprised since
we hadn't been in touch for quite some
time
he appeared on the screen at the
appointed hour looking like a million
dollars well-dressed confident with a
big smile
after exchanging pleasantries there was
a pause
I'm an imposter he said
and I'm miserable at work
I was stunned
his story came pouring out
42 years old happily married
two wonderful children prosperous
earning a seven-figure income
spending most of it living well
respected by his partners
and other professionals and he's a
domain expert
however
he knows he is neither is wise nor as
knowledgeable as people think
and more importantly
he hates to get up in the morning and go
to work
it's boring
it's repetitive
what he does has no impact to speak of
it doesn't move the needle
and he can't point to anything that's
truly his
until recently he believed he would
become an entrepreneur truly leading and
making a difference but now that dream
has died
he feels trapped
how sad
that story raises a few questions for us
when the counting is done in our lives
what will be left
will what I have done matter
will who I made the journey with matter
what about the quality of my
relationships
what about my prominence
what about my legacy
and since you mentioned it how can I
avoid living with regret
oh my these are daunting questions
so on a lighter note here's here's one
formula for living
some of you are familiar with these
three lines
work like you don't need the money
love like you've never been hurt
and dance like nobody's watching
[Applause]
those are words of Bojangles Robinson
who was a 1940s and 50s tap dancer and a
friend of the legendary musician Duke
Ellington
so let's take a step back
these are indeed extraordinary times
despite the recent Market downturn our
economy is generally vibrant new
employment opportunities are being
created and those jobs arise largely
from entrepreneurial efforts
they arise because individuals had
Visions they pursued and people in the
marketplace were willing to buy the
products and services flowing from those
visions
yet most of us feel
that we may be destined to become
Observers
highly paid managers investors advisors
sitting just outside this wave of
entrepreneurialism
many of us have hoped that someday we
might become entrepreneurs
yet statistically most GSB graduates do
not pursue entrepreneurial careers
in fact fewer than 35 percent of our
graduates 25 years out
classify themselves as having undertaken
something entrepreneurial or been
self-employed
yet
some 90 percent of entering first-year
MBA students Express a strong interest
in owning their own businesses
what happened
to derail these ambitions
well reality intervened
how can I think about being my own boss
I'm focused on getting a good job having
some kind of life
and paying off the student loans I've
incurred
I understand
I do understand
I offer for your considerations this
afternoon two of my very favorite quotes
they describe sharply contrasting
attitudes which are likely to lead one
into very different careers and indeed
lives
the first is from T.S eliot's the Love
Song of Jay Alfred Prufrock
no I am not Prince Hamlet nor was meant
to be
am an attendant Lord one that will do to
swell of progress
start a scene or two
advise the prince
no doubt an easy tool
deferential
glad to be of use
politic cautious and meticulous full of
high sentence
but a bit obtuse
at times indeed almost ridiculous almost
at times the fool
I grow old I grow old
I shall wear the bottoms of my trousers
rolled shall I part my hair behind do I
do I dare to eat a peach
I shall wear white flannel trousers and
walk upon the beach
I've heard the mermaid singing each to
each
I do not think they will sing to me
I have seen the moment of my greatness
flicker
such a powerful line I have seen the
moment of my greatness flicker
and I have seen the Eternal foot man
hold my coat and Snicker
and in short I was afraid
end quote
penetrating words
an attendant Lord
advising the prince
deferential
politic
cautious
glad to be abuse
afraid
elegant evocative lines
but a sad portrayal indeed
in contrast hear these words of w.h
Murray who led the Scottish Himalayan
Expedition
until one is committed there is
hesitancy the chance to draw back
always ineffectiveness concerning all
acts of initiative and creation there is
one Elementary truth the ignorance of
which kills countless ideas and Splendid
plans
that the moment one commits oneself then
Providence moves to
all sorts of things occur to help one
that would never otherwise have occurred
a whole stream of events issues from the
decision raising in one's favor all
manner of unforeseen incidents and
meetings and material assistance which
no one could have dreamed would have
come his or her way
I've learned a deep respect from one of
gerta's couplets
whatever you can do
or dream you can begin it
boldness has genius
power and magic in it
end quote
well you might say now that I'm at the
end of my Amiga or Ms experience how
would I become an entrepreneur if I
wanted to
are they born like 300 hitters are said
to be in baseball
or can they be made
before we talk about steps to take I'd
like to identify one thing that you
should not bring if you aspire to have
your own business
don't bring capital
don't bring money you say
how can Capital be anything other than
an advantage to a would-be entrepreneur
well one of the things we teach is that
the functions of the entrepreneur and
the capital supplier are very different
nowhere is it written that an
entrepreneur needs to supply capital
the disadvantage of having some money is
that one tends to define the scope of
one's venture according to the size of
one's resources
our working definition of
Entrepreneurship is the pursuit of
opportunity without regard to the
resources currently controlled
now if you think you might want to own
your own business match your outlook
with five attitudes that we've observed
in most entrepreneurs
one is an unending dissatisfaction with
a status quo
and that has two elements to it you're
not happy with the status quo and you
think you can do something about it
something better that is then is now
being done and build a business around
that notion
two itself a healthy self-confidence a
willingness to be lonely to make tough
decisions to stand on a level of the
organization chart with no peers
to have the buck stop with you
to be sometimes wrong in a big way
three what I would call responsible
competence
that you feel good about what you do
you think you can do more
and you're willing to stretch
four a concern for detail
there are very few successful
entrepreneurs I've seen who are broad
brush people in all aspects of their
lives
they may be broad brush in some areas
but that in but in critical matters
they're meticulous and if they're not
meticulous by Nature they're astute
enough to find a partner who is
critical details do matter
and finally five
perhaps most importantly
a tolerance for ambiguity
that should not be confused with the
love of risk because the best
entrepreneurs I know are constantly
asking themselves how to shrink risk out
of a situation
it means a willingness to accept an
uncertain future you're not sure you
have a job tomorrow you're not sure you
have an income
you're willing to give up the corporate
environment which you know the peer
group the customer base the routines
and you'll take on the ambiguity of
attempting to buy or start a venture
okay you say
you've matched your attitudes with those
that I've just described it and you pass
generally
maybe not a perfect correlation but a
pretty good match
how would you begin to become an
entrepreneur how does one get from here
to there
from employment to self-employment
I don't have an idea you say
I don't have money which you say is a
good thing
and I just don't know how or where to
start I have to pay off my debts
I have or hope to soon have obligations
to others personal obligations
but I am determined
to own my life
not lease it out in sections
my life is not for sale
when I go to work every day I shouldn't
have to leave my heart at home
the future is uncertain
but the best way for us to predict it is
to invent it
okay then don't be afraid to take a big
step if one is indicated
you can't cross a Chasm into small jumps
there's only one basic requirement in
terms of the process and that is to
figure out how to buy yourself some time
to be able to establish yourself apart
from your present job so that you can
use the morning of your energies on your
new venture
if you're going to work full time and
want to have any life outside your
professional Endeavors you're only going
to be able to give the evening of your
energies to pursue your your new venture
if you remain employed and new Ventures
demand first class morning Energies
first class enthusiasm intelligence
decision making
you've been given those capabilities
already you have those capabilities they
just haven't been called on fully
so you need to be able to leave your
present position and live for some
period of time while you translate your
dream into reality
stepping back a minute I hold firmly the
belief that entrepreneurship is a
reasonable career alternative
not for all but for any who might choose
it
you don't need to be impulsive
headstrong bombastic or flamboyant
you need no operating experience though
it usually helps
in short to be an entrepreneur there are
no external barriers
only those we internally impose
ask yourself this question
what would I do with my life
if I knew I wouldn't fail
I'm reminded of these words of Seneca a
sage of ancient Rome
it is not because things are difficult
that we do not dare
it is because we do not dare that things
are difficult
a principle for you in charting your
career path
is will I be in someone else's
organization or in my own
you know
in many of our courses here we are one
way or another examining the risks of
Entrepreneurship and properly so
but just for a minute
can we please examine
the risks of employment
while the company you work for will
hopefully
challenge you
promote you
compensate you well
flatter you
and give you buttons to push and
increasing numbers of people to manage
it may also
insinuate you into its culture
envelope you
and consume your entrepreneurial
Ambitions energies and perspectives
and remember The Uninvited Intruder in
your lives that doesn't knock before it
enters
risk aversion
it creeps
imperceptibly into your Consciousness
and decision making as the next few
years unfold
many although certainly not all larger
company executives are anything but free
how many of them like the former student
I zoomed with would love to leave but
don't know how to
where to go
can't afford it
and in many cases don't dare to
I've rarely met an unhappy successful
entrepreneur
but I met many unhappy successful
Executives of larger companies and
partners of Consulting and financial
firms
against which I have nothing
I'm just reporting what I've seen
you know your career
should not only be fun it should be fun
to go to work
your career should not only be fun
it should serve your life
it should serve your life not the other
way around
in effect we've just described a few of
the risks of not following the
entrepreneurial path tilling their soil
and their various locations creating
further value for their shareholders and
often not being challenged and not
having much fun
wouldn't you like to wake up when you're
40 45 or even 55.
and go to work with a skip in your step
to use a Warren Buffett phrase
that's in you know you're reading his
annual reports I see skip in his step
about every third annual report it's one
of his favorite phrases and I think it's
a wonderful phrase
indeed someone else's company versus
your own is more than a matter of how
you'll spend your work days it will
reverberate to every facet of your life
and yet the decision to become an
entrepreneur is even made more difficult
because each of us labors under the
burden of high expectations of close
friends
of family
of ourselves
each success in our career brings puts
more chips on the table
with each Victory come greater
expectations and in order not to
disappoint others or oneself a quote
safer
more customary
lower risk career courses often charted
but surely we recognize that there is no
absolute career safety
that risk cannot be avoided
we see that there is no right career
choice
many of the choices we've made in the
past up till now have
been easy ones choosing among attractive
Alternatives places to go to school and
places to go to work
now wait a minute where are the
guideposts what what am I supposed to be
doing
most of us realize that there's no right
choice we realize that intellectually
but we find it hard to accept
emotionally
certain risks in fact must be assumed
must be assumed consciously or not
and that's to me the operable question
to ask is what set of risks can I best
control
I don't like what the economists call
exogenous risks
uncontrollable risks I know I have to
assume risks some risk but
can we please make them execution risks
that's what I like
if I perform I'm rewarded
I start with a premise now
that one of our goals in life
is to Die Young
as late as possible
therefore what are some of the important
questions to be asking oneself if the
door to an entrepreneurial career is to
be left open
how would I Define my ideal work
environment is a good place to start
in terms of Partners ambiguity risks
peers status
power smaller versus larger Enterprises
the culture
structured versus unstructured the
importance of money some things like
that
as I sort through those things what are
important and what are less important to
me
what skills of mine need supplementing
and secondly do I think of supplementing
them by recruiting a partner or by
making myself more ready to go It Alone
three regarding the jobs now offered
were potentially available to me let's
take a look at the daily routine I would
follow the Avenues of advancement
the availability of a mentor and two
very important things
what doors are opened or closed
in my career path by assuming this job
I mean some of them produce awkward
transitions to places I might want to go
what are the natural transitions out of
this job and what are the the ones that
are more difficult and larger leaps
and the next question is how will I keep
my perspective
my entrepreneurial perspective and my
dream alive when I'm working for someone
else
how difficult will that be for me
I've learned that the easier it changes
to make
the less it usually matters
and that the older we get the harder it
is to choose change
indeed is one form of Hope
to risk change is to believe in tomorrow
so it behooves us to set a course
whereby any job we take moves us closer
to our career goal by building our
skills
but the path must be visualized in
advance
now back to the question of how to get
from employment to self-employment well
the most difficult part of any task is
Plato once said is the beginning of the
work
and that means both beginning the search
and sustaining the search for one's
entrepreneurial venture
whether it's a startup or a buyout
and maintaining a search in a sense is
like maintaining spiritual beliefs
they die if they're not nurtured atrophy
sets in
if you don't freshen that
entrepreneurial mentality by reading and
staying in touch with other
entrepreneurs and other searchers
atrophy will indeed set in and the Quest
for one's Venture will be abandoned as
that
naive idea I had back when I was at the
GSB
one of the really important guidelines
for the near term is
don't spend five years getting two years
experience
you require alternatives to be in a
strong position to make good decisions
so you need to look at a lot of
opportunities in order to refine your
judgment
okay so now what are the risks of
Entrepreneurship
failure
perhaps
but in the event of failure do you lose
your reputation no
do you lose your own money I sure hope
not
no so the answer to that one's no
do you lose other people's money yes
but that's where the term risk Capital
comes from
they're set up to take the risk they're
throwing mud at the wall a lot of them
and hoping some of it sticks and you're
not you're investing yourself huge
difference
a company won't hire you after a failure
wrong that's absolutely wrong
the biggest risk
is that you may become
constitutionally unemployable
you just don't want to work for somebody
else
you that could happen to you and I could
I'm that's a serious comment on my part
it may just Vector you enough
so that it chafes to go to work for
somebody else even though your own
Venture wasn't successful
um
so you have to go back somehow and
re-establish your credentials in order
to try again
there are many first-time failed
entrepreneurs who were subsequently
wildly successful
when are you ready for your own Venture
that's a question frequently asked I
don't know if I'm ready or not what do
you think
well Maxwell maltz in his book called
psycho-cybernetics
said very simply you're ready to do
something when you can visualize
yourself doing it
but there's a relatively short time
window
the right time is probably somewhere
between your age now and perhaps your
mid to late 30s
it's sooner rather than later
in percentage terms not many
entrepreneurs start or buy their first
Ventures after the age of 40 to 45.
and remember
entrepreneurs are just like you and me
and ability
what they have that is distinctive
our vision
and conviction
remember also that warm sense of
everything going well in your career may
only be the body temperature at the
center of the herd
keep in mind that
the many people who have waited on the
platform
for just the right train while life
passed them by
only to be saddled with so many
responsibilities and financial
constraints that they eventually
couldn't get on any train
don't let that be you
what are the rewards of the
entrepreneurial path
at the top of my list would be freedom
to stretch my capabilities
to put my in premature on a company
to create something
to have an ethical impact on others
and to have Financial Independence
now I know I know that it's
unfashionable around these Halls
even considered day class A
to talk about making money
is a byproduct we say with our noses
firmly in the air
well here's a comment that about money
that I offer without apology
there's a big difference between being
rich
and being wealthy
being rich is having money
being wealthy is having money
and time
the fundamental difference between
income and capital
Financial Independence when you're young
enough to enjoy it may be something
worth working for
it gives you an opportunity to have a
second career and a third career and to
be psychologically able to set out in
the New Direction in midlife
thus if you stay with a successful
organization you've created you do it
out of choice not necessity
now Switching gears
a short story
my ninth grade algebra teacher once gave
us a 40-minute test the last question
worth 25 percent
what is the custodian's name
though it was December
and we had seen him every day for three
months
no one knew his name
he became a person that day
not just a functionary
and our attitudes were permanently
affected
you know there's a Confluence of the
ethical and the Practical in life
so resolve to win from The High Road
and in your quest pause now and then to
ease the burdens of your fellow
Travelers I beg of you
you know it's been said that we all go
through life with partly broken hearts
any definition of success must include
service to others
we've all drunk from Wells we didn't dig
and been warmed by fires we didn't build
I reject the prevailing notion that the
pursuit of selfishness has overtaken the
possibility of compassion and I ask you
to reject it as well
not just by giving 500 to your local
charity or taking a titular position on
a hospital board but by voting devoting
your time and your abundance skills
which you've been given
to something worthwhile
really pulling on the oars and making a
difference
in areas where you're best qualified to
do so and are most passionate
returning to T.S eliot's image at the
end of my days I don't want the devil to
Snicker and hold my coat
if I've LED well and stood for something
Noble I will not have to worry
you know at this school
we teach you lots of things
we know you'll soon forget
it's true think back to your college
Years
how much content of those courses do you
remember
and the reason we do that is because we
don't know how to teach you
what you'll always need to know
compassion
commitment
concern
involvement
love
don't risk looking back on even part of
your life and realizing that you
suffered from a failure of kindness
it's been said that the only difference
between love and friendship
is the degree to which we can hurt each
other
I submit to you that the saddest phrase
of middle age is I wish I had
that regret
is inconsolable
how much better to be able to say with
open eyes I have dared and cherished no
regrets
it's undeniably tougher to create your
own opportunity than to be part of
someone else's but I've been down the
entrepreneurial Road as you heard and it
offers unparalleled exhilaration
if you choose to take that path ignore
the naysayers because very likely your
only supporters will be other
entrepreneurs and those with blind faith
in you
so do it if you will do it if you will
I've spent some of your time talking
about entrepreneurship and related
topics
yet I take full note that is mentioned
most of you will not become
entrepreneurs and I respect those career
choices
to each of you here today are I offer
these words of Ben Johnson
written in the early 17th century
it is not growing like a tree in bulk
does make a man better be or standing
along an oak 300 year to fall a log at
last
dry bald and Sear
a lily of a day is fair or far in May
although it fall and die that night it
was the plant and flower of light
in small proportions we just Beauties
see and in short measure
life may perfect be
end quote
that venerable elegant poem tells us
that the beautiful Lily that lived only
one day in May might have made more
impact than an imposing 300 year old
tree
impact
your effect on others
is how you will be known
how you will be remembered
in in a couple of weeks degree in hand
you'll head out to your Arena of choice
in this world it's not given to us Lee
to lead perfect lives but we can attain
perfection in short bursts
of altruism of kindness and compassion
and what should we strive for
not for a legacy
buildings all over this campus and the
world in fact display the names of
benefactors in bold letters
and 40 years later who knows who they
were or what they did
and few people really care
I don't intend to minimize the spirit or
the utility of the gifts
only the durability of the name
recognition
so let's think of the effect we have on
others of standing for a set of values
or principles and living them did I
really listen
did I invest
did I care
was our interaction a transaction or a
small step in the deepening of the
relationship
did I freely express my love
turning back to the topic of careers
each of us
each of us is equipped with everything
we need to experience a powerful life
full of success
full of incredible passion and joy
the difficult part is giving ourselves
the permission to live it
those are the words of Deborah Rosado
Shaw
or is said another way by May sartin
now I become myself
it's taken time
many years and places
I have been dissolved and shaken warn
other people's faces
now I become myself
in closing I say to you
nice start
paraphrasing Robert Frost
while the woods are lovely
dark and deep
you have Promises to Keep
and miles to go
before you sleep
so go out
touch the skies
and be special
because you are
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]